breaking tonight mixed messages about
the reopening of America a new survey
indicates more than 8 in 10 Americans
are worried that fewer regulations will
mean more infections meanwhile the
process President Trump calls a
transition to greatness rolls on with
considerable support on the ground but
there could be a hang-up on the next
round of congressional assistance chief
White House correspondent John Roberts
starts us off tonight with long could
even John record evening to you just a
few minutes ago President Trump
revealing that he will go off of his
dosing of hydroxychloroquine on Friday
that would mark 14 days since the last
case of corona virus was identified in
the West Wing there have been no new
ones since then and while the
president's feud with the state
government of Michigan continues he just
completed a much more constructive
dialogue with a bipartisan duo of
governor's thank you very much in the
Cabinet Room today President Trump
meeting with the governors of Arkansas
and Kansas both states in the early
stages of reopening states are opening
up some rapidly safely and we look
forward to that and I think we're gonna
get back we're gonna have some very good
numbers I project I think that we will
have a great transition period the
tensions over re-openings on display in
Florida today welcoming Vice President
Mike Pence governor Ron de santis going
off on the media you got a lot of people
in your profession who wax poetically
for weeks and weeks about our Florida
was gonna be just like New York wait two
weeks well hell were eight weeks away
from that and it hasn't happened with
all 50 states now in some degree of
rebooting a new Associated Press poll
finds 83 percent of respondents worried
that reopening z' will lead to new
infections in their areas but support
for continued restrictions is slipping
69 percent of respondents now supporting
a ban on gatherings of more than 10
people down from 82 percent last month
but as states open up more overseas
travel lanes may soon close
Vice President Mike Pence a new travel
bans may be imposed we're watching very
carefully what's taking place in South
America including in Brazil we saw in
recent days that we
significant spike in cases and
presidents made it clear that we we're
considering additional travel
restrictions President Trump today again
lashing out at the government of
Michigan
this time twitting that the Secretary of
State had mailed out absentee ballots to
seven point seven million people
claiming this was done illegally and
without authorization by a rogue
Secretary of State after Jocelyn
Benson's office said it was mailing
ballot applications and not actual
ballots the president revised his tweet
but continued to insist it was illegal
to which Benson replied poppycock I
cares act funding enabled us and my
colleagues Republican and Democrat in
other states to mail applications to
voters to request to vote by mail so
we're grateful for that federal
partnership the threat to withhold
funding comes as Michigan is dealing
with another crisis extensive flooding
from two dams that collapsed president
Trump would not say what funds might be
withheld nor would he thought was
illegal though it's clear he opposes
mass mailing ballots mail-in ballots are
very dangerous as tremendous fraud
involved and tremendous illegality
established case law in Michigan has
found that it is illegal for the
secretary of state or local clerks to
send out unsolicited absentee ballot
applications though it's possible that
Benson could claim because she's mailed
them to all seven point seven million
registered voters in the state of
Michigan there could not be any hint of
bias this is one of those cases Brett
that could well be decided with a trip
to the courts John Roberts live in the
North Lawn John thanks we'll follow that